Okay, um
welcome to the DDPS seminar today.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk unless you have uh
Uh if you have
if you do one, uh you're welcome to
unmute yourself and ask
those questions. Otherwise, please use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in Q&A session at
the end.
Uh second, today's uh DDPS seminar uh is
open to external audiences.
Uh
therefore, of course, no classified
discussion is allowed. So, uh please
watch out. Uh finally, the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in um our
YouTube channel. Um that's about it. Uh
now, let me introduce our speakers
today. Actually, we have two speakers
today. Uh it's it's an honor to host um
two speakers. Uh
uh the Tobias uh
Tobias and Alvaro uh will be our
speakers today. Uh both of them are from
DeepMind,
a uh the famous uh AI company also known
as the creator of the AlphaGo player who
defeated a human
professional Go player Lee Sedol from
South Korea.
Alvaro is a research engineer at
DeepMind focusing on applying graph
neural networks to physical simulation
and
reinforcement learning. Alvaro has
background in physics and computer uh
engineering and got his PhD at uh
Imperial College London in 2017 in
experimental ultrafast physics using
X-ray free electron lasers, uh so-called
xfel,
including applying machine learning to
improve xfel diagnostics.
Toby, Tobias, is a research scientist at
DeepMind also, but currently working at
the inter-
intersection of physics simulation and
machine learning. His background is in
physical simulation for computer
graphics.
And in his PhD in Zurich and postdoc in
Berkeley, he studied turbulent fluids,
fracture, and cloth the simulation,
and wrote the fluid solver, which is now
included in Blender.
Maybe he can talk more about the Blender
today.
Um, but
Toby and Alvaro will present today the
learning physical simulation with graph
network, which is a very exciting topic.
Uh, so please enjoy and expect a
wonderful talk from Toby and Alvaro.
Uh, now without further ado, let me pass
the baton to Alvaro first.
And but let me do that by asking one
random question just to set the stage
somewhat informal for both speakers and
audiences.
Okay, here is random questions.
Um,
for both of you, uh, the Toby and
Alvaro, um,
if you were the CEO of DeepMind, what
would you do? Uh, you may not want to be
a CEO, but if you just imagine it.
Anyone? And Alvaro or Toby?
That's a tough question. I mean, I would
say I would say
I'm kind of
I'm not in a position to answer it
because if anything, I'm kind of like
learning a lot by being in DeepMind
about like what a a can care about, and
especially, you know, how important is
for companies to care about applications
of the actual work that they do in the
real world to solve important problems.
So, like, uh if anything, yeah, I don't
think I'm no no no no way even close
where I could actually put myself in
that situation, but I am learning a lot
from what I see the CEO of our own
company do. So, um
yeah, that's that's my answer. Maybe
that's not what you expected, but uh
How about Tony? Uh Toby?
Yeah, that's actually tough one. Um you
don't know, like, DeepMind has a lot of
very different things they do. Um
I mean, I don't know, like, and
personally I I I I would be very
interested as a like, you know,
imaginary DeepMind CEO kind of I mean,
obviously like,
push uh the directions I'm interested in
more, right? But like, I mean, there's
it is kind of cool that there are so
many different things going on
currently. I mean, it would be
would be very interesting to see like
more like, I don't know, science and
engineering applications. But we I mean,
we're doing that in other ways already.
Um
I don't know. I don't have a good
answer.
Okay. Well, today's random question was
tough question. Okay, uh the Alvaro? Uh
please.
Okay. Thank you.
Um so, yeah, hi everyone. My name is
Alvaro Sanchez, and as uh Young-soo was
uh presenting me uh my research in here
at DeepMind, and today I'll be
presenting with uh my colleague Toby,
who is uh research scientist. Um so,
we're talking a little bit about our
research on learning simulation using
graph networks.
Uh so, the work that we're presenting
here was done in collaboration with our
great colleagues uh Misha Fortunato,
Jonathan Godwin, Rex Chen, Judy Illes,
Kaiming Peter Battaglia.
Uh and in this talk, we will actually
try to show the results from our recent
research, including some high-level
insights. Uh but we will also explore
some of the design principle behind our
models, including some more in-depth
detail about how graph neural networks
work. Uh
so, we hope we will have something for
everyone, independently of the level of
machine learning expertise. Uh plus, if
you find the model section maybe too
low-level, there will be some nice
videos with generalization examples
towards the end that we hope uh you will
enjoy.
So,
overall we believe simulation is
fundamental to science and technology.
But the first important question is why
we would want to learn simulation at
all?
So, the most common argument here is the
speed.
There are pretty well engineered
solvers. However, they're usually very
computationally expensive. And because
they require taking very small time
steps and very high high special
resolution, mostly something can
approximate the derivative. So, this
this is what makes them expensive that
they have to approximate kind of like
perfect spatial or temporal derivatives.
And these limits are there for classical
solvers, they don't necessarily apply to
machine learning models, which can often
learn subgrid dynamics or compensate for
large time steps or you know, large
spatial discretizations.
But beyond this, there are less obvious
reasons why it's a good idea to learn
simulation. Like, for example, neural
networks are often differentiable and
they have smooth gradients. And this can
be immensely helpful for solving inverse
problems, such as you know, optimizing
the shape of an airfoil or for like an
optical control problem.
Optimal control problem, sorry.
And sometimes we don't even know the
exact model of equations of the
parameters of a system that we want to
solve. So, running the exact simulations
is hard. You think of for example of
climate models or like modeling friction
and contact in robotics or or stuff like
that.
And finally, you know, writing
simulators is hard and even harder if
you want to write them for accelerators
or for GPUs or for TPUs. So, distilling
models into a learned model that can run
well on a modern accelerator can be very
useful too.
Now, this sounds so great and you know,
when we are used to kind of like
seeing news and headlines about machine
learning, usually we see things like you
know, 2 billion times acceleration. And
you know, this sounds amazing.
But actually, you know, if you start
digging more into the detail, actually a
lot of the models that are behind these
headlines, they often look like the one
in the right, where do maybe have a few
input in parameters that you fit into a
black box neural network, which then
outputs a single number or maybe a curve
or an image. And you know, of course,
the inference time for this neural
network is probably just a few
milliseconds. So, if the number you're
regressing is the output of a climate
model that normally runs on a super
computer, you very easily get a 1
billion factor improvement.
What is actually a bit less clear is
whether the model has actually learned
anything at all about the actual physics
or about the actual system. In most
cases, it's probably just fitting and
interpolating a curve. And neural
networks are very good at non-linear
interpolation. So, this is this is not
necessarily bad when it works and you
can train a model. But we know they are
usually bad at extrapolation. So, for
example, if you have a model predicting
the flow around an airfoil,
uh and then you try to learn on a lot of
samples where the airfoil is between 0
and 10° inclination, and then you try to
test this model on a 30° inclination,
the model will usually not give you a
good prediction for this, like most of
the models that what people are used to.
Um so, you really need to make sure that
the input space during training covers a
kind of like representing range of the
inputs that you expect to be able to
test on later.
And because you need all of this
training data to be representative of
any possible future inputs, now you have
to run tens of thousands of expensive
simulations to generate training data.
Uh so, you can later maybe run 10 cheap
simulations on this very narrow set of
parameters. Um
and you know, it get worse. If you want
to learn like a full model of a typical
general-purpose engineering simulations
like COMSOL or ANSYS, there's no way
that you can build a data set that even
begins to cover the whole input space of
the things that you could simulate with
it.
Uh and of course, now the situation of
the billion time acceleration starts to
look a bit bleak compared to the
headline.
So, our current research is focused on
exactly this issue. So, we try to train
models which actually learn reusable
knowledge, something like physical laws
that allows them to then be applied far
outside the data that it was trained on.
Um and we do this by structuring our
model right. Uh so, we can actually get
such strong generalization um along with
kind of like a lot of like nice
differentiable properties by really
imposing inductive biases in our model.
And like you can actually get things
like scalability, stability, speed,
versatility of the model across domains.
Um So, in general, most of the work
covered in this talk today is work from
our two recent papers from ICML 2020 and
I clear this year.
Um
I would also be playing a few videos. Um
they will probably look a bit choppy
over the video call.
Uh so, if you look at the project page
links on this slide, uh you can actually
look at the videos live.
But, you know, keep in mind that like
what we're doing is still basic research
and this problem is far from resolved.
So, we focus on generalization, but
there's lots of other angles that you
can study learn simulation from such as
accuracy, convergence properties. Um and
of course, we focus on kind of like an
end-to-end learned approach to learning.
So, you don't have to know a lot about
the system you're learning. Uh but of
course, combining learn components with
hard code solvers is also a completely
different area with its own benefits and
challenges.
So, before I tell you how about like how
our model works and talk about
generalization, let's look at the kind
of things that we can do with it.
So, these are rollouts of our model
trained on particle simulations of
water, sand, goop uh with the particle
representation that our model is working
on on the bottom and a rendered version
at top.
So, here's a very different simulation.
Now here we have flow from left to right
around a cylinder. So color is the
velocity field and this is on a 2D
triangular mesh.
So you can see that it's very hard to
see the difference between the model
prediction at the bottom and the
reference console simulation at the top.
Here's compressible flow around the
cross-section of an airfoil.
Um you can see the model correctly
captures things like socks and vortex
shedding.
For something a bit different, maybe
like cloth dynamics on a moving dynamic
mesh uh learned from a computer graphics
simulator.
And in this case, you can see even the
triangles adapting to the simulation.
And this is something that's uh Toby
will talk about later, too.
And finally, also a deformable plate now
on a tetra tetrahedral mesh. Uh and this
is also quasi-static simulation as
opposed to the inertial simulations
before. Uh now the interesting part is
like all of these simulations that we've
shown, they are learned using the same
model with the same architecture. Uh
whether it's 2D triangles, particles, or
3D tetrahedra.
So this is what we find very interesting
about our model, that a single model can
do all of this with virtually no changes
to the model.
So without further ado, let's actually
start looking at how we're doing all of
this. Um so what What do is we learn a
next step prediction model.
This is a model that takes the
simulation state at the current time
step and predict the state at the next
time step.
So, the model is an encode process
decode graph network. So, at high level,
at every time step, we encode the system
state into a graph.
Then the neural networks process the
information on that graph, and then they
decode back the updated system state.
And all of these using jet
reasonable general purpose components.
Now, our main design principle behind
all of these general purpose inside
these neural network components is this.
So, essentially, recognizing that neural
networks have issues with extrapolation,
uh then we can actually make their life
easier by by, you know, recognizing what
the problem is here and try to design
components that would make them better
at extrapolation.
And, you know, giving machine learning a
little bell is not very unfair. Like,
help is not very unfair. Uh so, one of
the most important things that Sir Isaac
Newton acknowledged is that he was
standing upon the shoulders of giants,
and that, you know, he was not starting
from scratch, but benefiting from all of
the work that came before him.
So, in general, we found that it is very
useful to give neural networks the
opportunity to do this. And the way we
achieve this by adding inductive biases
to our networks.
So, an inductive bias is anything that
allows a model to prioritize one
solution over another.
So, if you want to say this differently,
uh
can can you still hear me?
Yeah, yeah, I can see your slides and I
can I can hear you. Yeah.
Yeah. So, um
I I don't know what what happened.
If uh if if if you want to say this
differently, you know, an inductive bias
from my Bayesian point of view it's a
way to give our model a prior over what
to do in the absence of data.
Uh
Alvaro,
somehow um
we cannot see your slides.
Okay.
I think someone else shared the screen
for a second. I'll I'll share them
again. Oh, okay. I see.
Can you see them now?
It's starting to share contents.
Yeah, now. Okay. Perfect. Let me say a
word to audience. Please do not share
anything except the speakers.
I wish I
I know how to you know prevent that.
Okay, please go ahead Alvaro. Sorry
about that. Yeah, no no problem.
So yeah, so essentially we usually find
that models with a strong inductive
biases are are much more data efficient
and can generalize much better to unseen
scenarios.
So let's look at a simple inductive
bias.
Imagine we're trying to model the
position of this falling piano using a
black box
neural network.
Now, the first thing that we can
consider is to use a neural network to
produce the next position of the piano
given the previous position and
velocity.
And you know, a model like this one will
have to spend training time and possibly
capacity just to learn that usually the
position the position of the piano at T
plus one is close to the position of the
piano at the previous time step.
Um
So instead, we can ask the neural
network to predict the difference
between the previous position and the
next position.
Now, the model prior we have it very
easy to indicate that the piano will
remain on the previous position just by
having the neural network output zero.
Um but of course, we can take this one
step farther because we know that this
system is actually driven by inertial
dynamics and in the absence of forces,
it's not really position but velocity
that remains constant.
So this model will still have to learn
that a piano moving with constant
velocity will in most cases continue
moving with that velocity.
So instead, we can ask the neural
network to predict a correction to the
initial trajectory. So, this way, if the
neural network outputs a zero, then the
object will continue moving with
constant velocity.
So, now that now this model has an
inertial prior, and the neural network
can focus the learning and the capacity
to actually learn the non-trivial parts
of the dynamics, like for example, the
effect of gravity or the effect of air
friction.
So, what we do is we add many useful
inductive biases like this to our model.
And these are inductive biases that are
well known to be very general in many
problems. Uh one of them, for example,
is a spatial equivariance. You know,
this is kind of like saying that if we
place this box 1 m to the right, the
physics should be the same that that
were they were before. Uh or local
interactions that like, you know, maybe
particles are often more strongly
influenced by particles that are nearby
than particles that are farther away.
Um such um we know that, you know, if we
were to place this this kind of like box
1 m to the right, then the physics would
be the same uh according to kind of like
the first inductive bias. So, I'm not
kind of like to go into the full set of
um into inductive biases that we have
here, but, you know, we'll we'll just
say kind of like a few to give you an
idea of like why we constructed our
model in the way we did it.
So, first, we're mentioning that like
we're using graph networks. Uh and we
will see that graph networks are graph
of
are a type of neural networks that allow
to very naturally express many of these
inductive biases.
So, let's actually see how our graph
neural networks work.
Imagine we're working with this
gravitational system.
And many of you will be familiar, you
know, with uh the simplest of neural
networks, the multi-layer perceptron,
which takes a vector as input and
returns a vector as output.
So, we could put the position and
velocity of each body into a vector and
feed it through the MLP.
The problem is that by doing that, we're
imposing an ordering.
Um so, if now we were to ask the neural
network the same question, but giving
the inputs in another order, the answer
will not be guaranteed to be the same.
So, the MLP has to learn the interaction
of all of these bodies separately, just
to eventually figure out that gravity
works in the same way for all of them.
A better representation of vectors for a
system like this one are graphs, because
by definition, nodes and edges in a
graph don't have a specific ordering.
And in these graphs, you know, maybe we
can still have each node representing an
object, and store some node features,
such as the position, mass, velocity uh
of the particles in those objects.
And we can also store features in the
edges connecting the nodes. For example,
something like a spring constant, if the
particles are connected with springs.
And finally, we may also have some
global context that affects all of the
particles, such as like the
gravitational contact constant, if we
want to change it between simulations.
So now, all we need is a neural network
that is able to operate on these graphs,
and this is what graph networks do.
A graph network simply takes a graph
with node, edge, and global features,
and updates all of those
representations. So, we can, for
example, ask the graph network to
produce the position of a node at the
next time step.
The magic is that all of the updates
that the graph network
does uh happen in a
permutation-equivariant way,
independently in the of the order in
which we specify the nodes and the
edges.
Um and this is possible because graph
networks were based on something called
message passing.
So, let me explain in detail for those
of you that are not familiar with this
model what message passing is.
Let's start looking at a single edge of
the graph.
So, for that edge, we can take uh we can
build a vector by concatenating
uh the vector feature of that edge,
the vector feature of the two nodes that
are connected by the edge and the global
vector feature.
And then, we can apply a neural network
to this vector to compute an updated
vector associated with the edge, which
we will refer to as the message.
And we know many forces in physics are
typically defined as pairwise
interactions such as this. Uh so, we can
actually think of pairwise messages as
an inductive bias.
Now, we actually repeat the process to
update the representation for all of the
edges, but using the same neural
network.
And this also imposes a prior that the
update function should be the same for
all of edges, similar to how the laws of
physics are universal.
After we have updated the edges, then we
have to update the nodes. And now, we do
something similar. We start looking at
one node, and for this node, we take all
of the messages that this node receives
using a sum.
And this is closely related to the
superposition principle in physics, and
how forces can usually be just added up.
Um and of course, in this case, instead
of forces, we'll be operating over
learned representations rather than just
forces, but the principle the main
principle still apply.
And then, once we have aggregated these
messages, then we build another vector
with the feature vector of the node, the
aggregated messages, and the global
vector.
And again, we give this vector to
another neural network, and then we use
this to update the node representation
this time.
Um and note that in this case, uh a node
can only update itself based on its
neighbors. So, imposing a prior this is
So, this is imposing a prior of local
interactions.
And similarly to before, then we repeat
the same process to update the
representation for all of the nodes
using the same neural network.
So, these two steps is what makes the
network kind of like uh equivalent to
permutations of the nodes because
actually, it doesn't care in which order
you provide you provide the nodes on the
edge and the edges.
So, there's usually an additional update
step uh which allows to update the
global features of the graph.
But, this particular update is not
local. So, for this work we don't use
it.
Um
but like you know in some of other work
you you may be seeing that people
actually use global updates.
So, now that we know
that we will be using graphs and why, I
will leave you with Toby who will
explain how these models are connected
to our domains and actually go through
the results and the generalization.
Let me share my slides. Um
I think you have to unshare cuz my share
button is grayed out.
Oh, it's still grayed out.
Ah, there we go.
Can you see my uh screen?
Yeah.
All right.
So, yeah. Thanks Alvaro for the
introduction. Um
So, let's talk about uh how this
actually works for a concrete system. Um
So, specifically let's look at the
encoder um
and what's happening there.
So, the encoder is a module that takes
the input set of nodes and builds a
graph. And then we can use it in the
graph processor to process and then pass
messages on the graph.
And so, our model can deal with various
types of systems. So, we showed that we
specifically looked at particle systems
and meshes.
And so, for meshes building a graph is
kind of a trivial operation, right?
Because a graph and like a mesh is
already a graph. So, we have mesh nodes
and mesh edges.
And so, we can directly use those to
build a graph by just saying like every
node in the mesh is a node in the graph
and every edge connecting these in the
mesh is an edge connecting them in the
graph.
If you have a particle system on the
other hand, we can use the particles as
nodes and we can just connect them by
proximity.
So, that means that
we take a particle and within a certain
radius
we will connect all other particles in
that radius by an edge to build a
locally connected graph.
And then as we as I already mentioned
before um
we can encode features into these graph
nodes and edges.
So, with this example of a particle
system representing liquids, that would
be something like each particle's
position, velocity, and maybe a particle
type. Is it like a liquid? Is it a
boundary particle or whatever?
And then we could use this graph and
pass messages on it.
But it turns out we can actually do even
better than this. So, if we don't encode
the position directly into a node and
instead encode the positional difference
between two nodes into an edge
then we get translational equivariance
basically for free, right?
This is a property that we know that
pretty much all of a lot of the physical
systems that we care about have and our
network can then exploit.
And there's a lot of other things that
are very similar that we can do and I
think this is just to give you the basic
idea of
why we're doing this. It's like we we're
trying to reduce the amount of
information that a single neural network
can see as an input as much as possible.
So, for example, due to using graph
nets, we only need to reason about the
local neighborhood around each node,
right?
And due to encoding relative distance in
edges as opposed to like the absolute
position in a node the network inputs
will look the same for a similar
neighborhood wherever that may be
located in the simulation domain.
And so, this property allows the model
to for example to be used on uh
systems that are much larger and have
higher position values than has been
seen in training. And this is something
we going to going to look at later more
in detail.
Okay, so this is kind of how we can
build a graph. Um and as I was saying,
we can run message passing on this
graph.
And then as a last step, we have to kind
of decode this graph and get back our
next system state.
And so this is the job of decoder and
updater.
So again, let's look at this example we
had from our liquid system using
particles.
And one obvious thing here what we could
do is we can just say like we take the
features stored in the graph nodes and
just
add an MLP on that and then decode that
into like say the next position, right?
But as Alva already mentioned earlier,
this makes the problem just
unnecessarily hard. So in practice, we
can predict something like an
acceleration exploiting the inductive
biases of inertial motion.
And this is kind of nice because what it
means again is that if you just have a
neural network giving you a zero
prediction, it would just keep all the
particles flying with their previous
velocity. So that is a useful bias to
exploit and we only have to
predict the deviation from that.
So there's a lot of model
to talk about, but I think like you get
hopefully the basic idea how we
constructed our method. Um
And why we did so, right? So we encode a
system into a graph, we do message
passing on the graph.
Decode back to the next step.
And we try to pack as much inductive
biases we can in that process.
Um
And the beauty of all of this is that
the actual core model can remain exactly
the same for all of these different
systems, right?
Whether we simulate liquids or cloth or
aerodynamics and whether that's an
inertial or quasi-static simulation or
like if it's particles, triangle meshes,
tetrahedra, what have you, right? So,
the only thing we need to do different
for these systems is
how we actually encode or what
quantities we encode and how we decode
them.
So, we already seen for example that for
particles we can encode node positions
and decode to accelerations of these
particles.
But, if you have for example a
continuous field like these velocity
fields in the Eulerian fluid
simulations, all right? We can just
encode the samples of the velocity field
at the mesh nodes
into our graph nodes.
And then we can decode the changes in
these fields, right?
Or if you have incompressible flow, then
we do the same for a density field in
addition to the velocity field.
And so like it will come to no surprise
then that what this basically amounts to
is learning the right-hand side of an
underlying PDE of these systems, right?
And we're not only learning the PDE, but
we also learn all the nasty
implementation details surrounding
discretization schemes, parameters that
you might not want to encode, global
effects like pressure, like everything
basically that makes writing classical
simulators hard. That's all learned in
our model.
The only thing you have to deal with is
getting our variables out and updating
them.
All right. So
So, this is basically how you learn a
next step model. And once you have such
a model, you can use it to make
predictions.
So, because we are learning these
temporal simulations or dynamic
simulations,
what we do is we unroll these
We unroll our model to get a simulation
trajectory, right? So, that means we
start with an initial state
and we apply our model to this initial
state and we get the next step and on
this next step we evaluate the model
again until we get like a rollout that
we can then render for example as this
animation or look at in some other way.
And
so
this is it's actually kind of surprising
that this works at all because normally
what happens if you train a model on
like predicting the next step
and then unroll it for hundreds of step,
you will get something like the
animation on the right, right? So this
tends to explode. And the reason for
that is error accumulation.
And
so even if you have a model that's very
accurate, there will always be some
slight imperfect predictions and further
steps will compound this error.
And this is something that's not
particularly surprising. It also happens
in classical solvers as well and this is
why we all have like these fancy
integration schemes. But this is much
much worse for learned models of
dynamics.
Because eventually what will happen is
that the accumulated error can form
states that haven't been seen in
training.
This is particularly true for things
like physically invalid states. So here
we have an example of like particles
getting too close and overlapping.
Or it could also be things like
divergences in incompressible flow.
Anything that hasn't been seen in the
training data because it can't be for
this physical system.
And because neural networks are dumb as
we mentioned before and they don't
extrapolate well, given such an input
they haven't seen, they will give us a
very random prediction and particularly
often it leads to these exploding
trajectories.
So often what people do is things like
training over multiple steps. But what
we found is much simpler and works a lot
better is using training noise.
What we do is during training we corrupt
our input data with Gaussian noise and
ask network to compensate for it.
In this way the network can learn to
like A see these states which are
slightly deviation from our like
training set input, but also they can
correct some physically invalid states.
For example, such these unexpected
divergences, right?
So, let's have a closer look at one of
our rollouts.
So, this is the rollout again trained on
one step and we roll it for a few
hundred steps.
You notice there's definitely no
explosions here.
But also like even in this very chaotic
regime, we actually remain pretty close
to the reference simulation on the right
at all times, which is also kind of
interesting to see.
And so, this is a rollout of a few
hundred steps, but that's not
necessarily the limit, right? So, you
can basically unroll indefinitely. So,
here is an example where you just keep
unrolling for I think 40,000 steps in
total.
Um
and you see like
the dynamics
just keeps being the same. So, we don't
have any like super bad build-up of
error.
And again, this is just trained on next
step prediction as before.
Okay. And yeah, now finally, I think we
should talk about generalization, which
is kind of the thing that motivated a
lot of our work.
So, for that, let's look at this simple
example. So, we have a model that we
trained on this little 2D domain on the
left. So, this is There's really That's
the only thing that's in the training
set. We have a set of like these single
water cubes, which fall onto a
randomized line obstacle. And there's I
mean some variations. The cube might be
slightly different size or this obstacle
might have might be slightly different
orientation or position.
But that's kind of all there is.
But then at test time, what you can do
is we can take this model and we apply
it to a very different scene, right? So,
first of all, we have have a bigger
domain.
And you also have a continuous inflow.
And you can immediately see that the
dynamics that we get here are
qualitatively different from what we
have on this training set on the left,
right? So, neither this continuous
inflow nor these water vortices have
been observed in training at all.
And this is exactly that type of
generalization that you really wouldn't
expect to get with like a learned model,
unless you construct it particularly to
do so.
But,
we already know kind of why this works.
And this is because of all of the
inductive biases that we have built into
our model, as I will explain earlier.
So, for example, each node in the
network only sees a particle in its
local neighborhood, right?
And even if you have a very different
dynamics on a global scale, chances are
that a similar neighborhood has been
actually observed in training at a local
level. So, for example, we have seen
um like the dynamics around water
surfaces, or like how particles interact
with the box boundaries, or the dense
blocks of water just move around.
Oops. Um so,
due to all of the locality invariances,
the network inputs for all of these
little neighborhoods is kind of they
actually look quite a lot the same. So,
it's not surprising that the neural
network can actually give us a good
prediction for those.
And the effect that it has is that
encourages our model to learn local
universal laws, something that's very
much like the actual underlying physics,
as opposed to overfitting to some more
global feature of the training data,
which is something you see often in in
learned models dynamics.
All right. Um so, let's look at a bit of
a bigger bigger example.
Um so, so this is an example of meshes
this time. And again, we have a training
set that's the box on
the left corner. So, we have just a
bunch of variations of these rectangular
flags. And then at test time, we apply
it on this very different windsock with
tassels.
And um so, I mean,
the shape is different. It has never
seen the cylinder. But also, this mesh
this mesh is much bigger than the
training meshes, right? So, we have 10
times as many nodes. You can see all the
little triangles here.
And again, like this is a close-up here
with the training and the test domain
side by side.
And so, the fact that we can actually
run these simulation at test time on
much bigger scale is actually also quite
interesting by itself, right? Because
what it means is that the our training
data doesn't necessarily have to be
expensive. Because that's the point
that's often made about um
that you have to like balance the cost
of like training a model versus the the
thing you that you can use it for. But
like with this kind of method, you can
actually train on cheap lowest data and
then at test time scale it up to
something more complex.
All right. As a last point, um
let's look at
at meshes.
And this is relevant because a lot of
simulators like finite elements, which
are very popular simulators in
engineering particularly, they use
meshes as representations. Um and that's
for good reason cuz I mean, a lot of
domains like the ones here,
you could represent them as like voxel
grids, but it's not particularly
efficient to do so.
And also, if you operate on meshes,
there's a lot of nice tools from
continuum physics that you can exploit
to
give you nice solutions to these PDEs
that you're solving.
But the fact that we are working on
things like meshes and graphs is
actually quite unusual in the field
because the vast majority of machine
learning research for physics prediction
does that on 2D regular grids.
That's of course because um these are
well-understood convolution
architectures like ResNets and U-Nets
are very prevalent and well-understood.
Um so, a lot of you would just use them.
But also, there's a bit of an impression
that learning on graphs only works for
small systems.
And one of the points we try to make in
our research is that that is not
actually longer true. So, um learning on
graphs can actually scale. Now that we
can use meshes and graphs as
representations, we might as well do so
and reap all the benefits that these
representations bring us. And these are
exactly the same that they bring to
classical simulators.
So, here's an example of
one of these nice swatches we get using
meshes and that is just um
adaptivity, right? So, this is one of
these aerodynamic examples that Alvaro
showed you earlier.
The flow around an airfoil wing. And the
whole simulation domain is 4 m, but
these this wing tip
region, which is apparently very
important for these simulations, we get
sub-millimeter accuracy.
And that's with a mesh of 5,000 nodes.
If you were to put this on a grid, you
would need a uniform grid of 40 billion
nodes for the same precision.
But we can take it even further.
In this cloth example earlier, you might
have noticed that the triangles keep
shifting during simulation.
Uh and this is because the optimal
triangle size we kind of want for the
system but also over the course of the
simulation, right? Um
You might want to have smaller triangles
where these bends and folds are, which
of course move if the flag blows in the
wind.
And this is actually something we can
learn, too, right?
So, what we do here is we learn a graph
net model, much like the one we used for
dynamics prediction. And we predict a
sizing field.
Which is basically a spatial map which
indicates where in the simulation domain
we need higher resolution and where we
can get away with coarser triangles.
And this sizing field can then be used
to dynamically adapt the resolution
during the simulation or but by passing
it to a very generic remesher. And all
of the cloth examples that are that
we've shown you used this method and it
seems to work very well even in the
generalization setting.
Here's an explicit example for we can
see the sizing field and
the simulation side by side. You can see
that like where these bends and folds
appear and propagate by the wind blowing
the flag, there will be smaller
triangles appearing in in the meshes as
well.
All right. Um I think it's time to wrap
up our talk. Um I think the general
message we have everyone is that um
straightforward application of deep
learning to simulation often results in
models that don't do so well on
generalization particularly.
But it is totally possible to construct
models that do generalize, right? Uh and
we believe the key to do so is carefully
constructing them with inductive biases
in mind.
And in particular, I think uh I hope we
convinced you that uh
graph and mesh representations are very
powerful and promising way forward for
learning the dynamics of physical
systems.
Because they have a lot of these uh nice
properties that we want from a learned
model.
And as you said earlier, um
our research mostly focused on these
end-to-end learned models, um
but there's a lot of other things you
can do um
in the domain of learning physical
models. And for example, mixing learned
components with like hard-coded solver
components or trying to interpret uh
the the networks you have learned and
trying to distill equations out of that.
And there's a lot of cool work in that
direction. So like I put some links on
you uh on the slide for you to look at
if that's something you're interested
in.
And um
Yeah, so finally I We believe this is
really an exciting area to do research
in. There's lots of more open questions
um and no shortage of hard problems to
tackle, but we feel we feel like we're
making some progress here and um
we're really excited particularly in
looking more into adaptivity. Um we're
also kind of curious how far you can
actually scale these models up in terms
of like real problems in in science and
engineering.
And again, like there's these links to
uh to website for these two papers again
on the slide where you can find like
both the paper and also like all the
videos that we showed here, which
probably like didn't play you know, it
fell over the video chat. All right,
that's it from us. Thank you so much for
joining.
Okay, thank you so much for the great
talk, both for Alvaro and the Toby.
Um we will have a Q&A session. We have a
um
a lot of questions, by the way. Okay,
let's
Let's start from the the beginning.
Um okay, the rab um
asked, "How do you deal with a node that
have a higher degree
than other nodes? Wouldn't that change
the size of that local node vector?"
So, so in principle, because of how the
node that the updates work,
um
we never look at a whole neighborhood
and put that into a vector and give that
to a near neighbor. What we do is we
look at all of the edges one by one, and
the edges always have two nodes, and
then when we update the node, we take
all of the edges, and then we sum them.
So, like that sum,
the out the size of the output of that
sum is the same regardless of whether
you have one neighbor or do you have 10
neighbors. Um and there's a lot of
research that like, you know, some other
people sometimes take the mean instead
of the sum or the max. In principle, the
sum is the most powerful powerful one,
but for some applications, actually
taking the mean is better. The only
important thing is whatever op you take,
you want it to be
uh permutation invariant, because you
don't want the output to depend in the
order of of which, you know, you maybe
specify the nodes. So, the sum is is
commutative, so it's it's kind of like
permutation invariant by definition.
Okay. Uh Toby, do you want to add
anything to that?
No, I think that's exactly it. Okay,
thank you.
Uh next question is by Betty. Uh how do
you ensure conservation law, for
example, mass, momentum, and energy
conservation? Um is are they satisfied
in the system you are studying?
I guess the simple answer is that
they're not. Um just like uh as Alborz
mentioned, there's a few inductive
biases we put in.
Um energy conservation specifically is
not something we did put in, right? So,
just like um
some drift we can get in these
variables. And in general, we found that
um if we do it well, they are not too
bad. So, like certainly like if you look
at the simulations, uh there is no kind
of explosion in energy for example as
like you will have another of solvers
where the integration goes bad, right?
But there there might be drift in things
like accumulating divergences and things
like that. And I mean, this is something
we're interested in like exploring a bit
more what you can actually do to give
you better guarantees on these things. I
think I mean, currently
um
what we do is kind of you kind of um
want to try to do two things with a
model um unless you specifically have
something built in that like um
guarantees you that, which is if you try
if your model error low enough, and also
you through for example training noise,
give your model inputs that um
a little bit out of the training range,
you kind of are
um making sure that you don't get any
crazy results, right? But you don't
necessarily guarantee anything beyond
that. I'm not sure if you have something
to add to that, Alborz.
Um
yeah, not not not much. Just say that
like
there's yeah, different models may have
may make different compromises. So, like
even simulators, when we say you know, a
simulator conserves energy uh very well,
often it does so because it compromises
with something else. Maybe it has a
constraint satisfaction states that it
that it kind of like is particularly
targeted at energy conservation. And in
by solving that constraint, it's
actually moving something else that
could have been like better in a
different way. So, like in that sense,
we can also we also know how to
introduce these these constraints to
neural networks.
Uh we're just not doing in these papers,
but we would know have to do it, I
think.
Okay.
Sounds good.
The next question is by Mark Mark.
How much of the work is publishable and
how much is appropriate?
Three.
I mean, everything we cover in the talk
is published. Also, this is these two
papers here mostly. So, there's not
things super secret. I mean, there's
more things we're working on, but we're
not ready yet. But once it is, we will
publish that. For the first paper,
there's even code out and like some of
the actually all the data sets and the
code is out there. It's also like a
there's a link on this webpage on top.
For the the newer paper on the matches,
we're preparing a release for for code
and and data sets, but it's not there
yet. I'm I'm not sure how long it will
take.
Okay. Wonderful. All right. Next
question is by Matt. Do you have
quantitative error metrics beyond the
video?
You know, looking good.
I mean, we have
some I mean, so the it's like always a
little bit hard to measure uh
quantitative error on these like
dynamical simulations. So, I mean, we
did the obvious thing, which is we
measure one step
mean square error for all of these. And
we also measure the error over
like a window of time steps, right? So,
like over the first 50 time steps or
like first 100 or whatever, right? And
these are indicative of certain
different properties. Um And you can
compare them to other methods.
In general, like it is true that like
the lower them the error goes, on
especially one-step error, the better
like your rollouts will become. But like
certainly for especially for chaotic
systems, at some point these errors stop
making sense, right? Because even like a
small perturbation at step one will like
down the line then give you very high
error, even though the behavior is
completely reasonable. And this is
something that's also true of classical
solvers, right?
And there's probably other
metrics you can look at like statistical
um
what is like looking at like energy over
frequencies like that? We haven't really
done that.
Okay. Okay, next question is by Kyle.
For a granular system where the locally
connected grains change as a function of
time, how do you handle creating and
destroying edges?
So for the edges, we just use a spatial
hashing algorithm for computing the
nearest neighbor distance with this
within a certain radius.
We never tried to optimize that part of
the code too much. So actually we were
recalculating everything at every step.
Um
So in principle, you know, edges just
come and go at every step after you
compute the next positions. Then in some
of the simulation we actually add
particles in the middle of the
simulation.
I don't remember if we remove particles
in any of the demos. I don't think we
do, but like in principle that's not a
problem. You can just you can because
our model only takes a single step of
inputs.
It's a just a transition model. It
doesn't have a recurrent state. You can
very easily just like add more things or
remove things, add edges, remove edges.
You you you can just like have that
flexibility usually. And in the mesh one
for example,
we're just recomputing the entire mesh
and re-interpolating the positions and
that that works fine.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Oh my goodness, still the questions are
pouring out. Okay.
It's almost out of control.
Okay, the next question is by Yasaman.
How much of the computational cost do we
save with graph networks versus
numerical simulations using
physics-driven models?
Okay, who's going to answer that?
this is also something that's a bit hard
to measure. I mean in the in the
Now in your paper we have some
performance comparisons. So like
generally like especially if you have a
numerical simulation that's very
expensive, you can get a lot of gains.
So I mean we have numbers with like just
like end-to-end wall clock time 10 to
100 times faster than the reference
simulator.
Um but it's like it's always a little
bit tricky to compare that. A lot of
these simulators uh don't have like
GPU-accelerated versions, for example.
But I think like one of the point that
that's worth mentioning here is I think
this is kind of like one of the benefits
you model can give you is that in areas
where it's really hard to have a very
fast hand-written solver,
um these models can shine particularly
well, right? So, like if you have just a
very simple domain, you have like I
don't know, a box uh
with fluids and you have periodic
boundary conditions, and there's very
fast solvers you can use to solve that
problems. Like a learned model might not
be necessarily faster there.
Uh however, if you have a very complex
domain, which is the case in a lot of
these engineering applications with
complicated meshes, boundary conditions,
whatever, like a lot of these
um
nice properties that traditional solvers
like multigrid solvers or whatever have
kind of break down the more complicated
the domain becomes, right? Um
whereas uh a neural network model can
actually learn very
very nice approximations to like still
give you large speedups here. And this
is the same as true also for time.
So, like our model, for example, it can
kind of learn something like an internal
fancy integrator, and we can take much
larger time steps than a classical
solver, right? Because
the all of these traditional things like
CFL condition or whatever don't
necessarily apply to our model because
it can kind of look at more like bigger
coherent structures and not only at like
the single-cell level.
Okay, thank you. Uh the next question is
by Xiao. Uh why is GNNs
superior to CNN? Can you briefly explain
uh when we want to use GNN instead of
using CNN for image-to-image prediction?
So, uh that's a very interesting
question. So, like I I don't think CNNs
or GNNs are really uh opposed to each
other.
Often often we actually often use CNNs
for like some of the work that we do.
Actually recently we we published
something in a workshop in ICLR. Let me
share the link here.
So this is essentially or actually
that's meant to be two links.
But it didn't yeah. There you go. So
essentially this added
this is
this work that we did modeling PDEs and
we were modeling PDEs on grids in this
case and for this one we actually used
convolutional neural networks because we
found they were sufficient for that
domain.
And actually when we tried graph neural
networks they were fine. But you know
graph neural networks tend to be a bit
more expensive to evaluate. So what I
would say is if for your application a
CNN works fine then
I will not discourage people from using
CNNs. If if you suspect your model
doesn't have enough like you know
reasoning capabilities then there's a
whole spectrum from like a CNN a
transformer and a graph neural network
that you can start exploring. And you
know
in this in a way like graph neural
network is the one that can model the
interactions in the kind of like in a
way that is closer to how like most
simulators model interactions.
So like is this a continuum of models
really and you should just pick whatever
works best for your application. So I
wouldn't
I don't kind of like play I just I just
think overall if you don't know what's
going to work and you want to invest on
one then you can just do the job network
graph network usually it will work and
it gives you flexibility for like you
know non non kind of like a sparse non
like uniform grids.
But overall yeah like I
unless you unless you have like long
range dependencies that are very hard to
reason about or and like using kind of
like a convolution sort of approach I I
wouldn't discourage people from trying
CNNs for their problems.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you. The next question is by
Charles. Would you comment on why the
error in your
flag wind simulation predictions plateau
as time grows in your paper? I'm
particularly interested in having low
errors at
some final time and I'm worried that
using, you know, the update from, you
know, previous time step to next time
step will propagate the errors. Um
Thanks for the talk, by the way.
So so that's very similar to the point I
raised for unlike that it's hard to
measure error. So I think for this flag
particularly what we see is the
coherence error, right? So what I mean
by that is like the error that you see
at the plateau as if the flag that we
have
and the flag in the reference simulation
are in a different angle, right? Because
like the little differences in the first
few steps made like the flag just like
swing into a different direction, right?
And um
so like at
at these long ranges
our simulation that's like often after
like 50 or maybe 100 time steps, like
most of the error measured is the
coherence. The main thing that we wanted
to show with this graph is that the
error doesn't increase beyond that,
right? So we don't have any uncontrolled
stability. So we only the only thing we
have is that this kind of like um
chaotic behavior
accumulating over time.
And so so I don't know if you
if you're looking at like more So yeah,
there's two things. Like one it's good
to know that it does plateau, right? So
there's no no explosion. The other thing
if you actually want to compare more
like what's a more accurate model, you
may want to look at just like MSEs in
very short
time horizons. So like just at the one
step or like the few step error. This is
much more indicative of the of the
final performance there. And the other
thing is you can do like you can again
like start looking at these um
kind of more
I don't know domain dependent
statistics, right? So for cloth you
could look at, okay, do your triangles
actually stretch at some point, right?
Or for um
for incompressible flow, you can easily
like oh, do you actually have any
singularities
um or divergences um
that appear over time and something like
that, right?
Okay. Uh thank you. Uh next question is
by Shao Shao you. Uh
well, it's just a comment he made. The
graph is a good idea for mesh-based
modeling compared to CNN and LP. It is a
good choice for simulation on FEA, graph
element network. Um
however, personally, I feel most of the
papers are just fancy ways to
approximate finite difference or finite
volume. Uh imagine uh if you have a poor
scheme, poor uh mesh, um it is still
able to tell you something about
physics, even though it might be
incorrect. They behave much like the the
prediction results you have, but since
you have data to correct the model,
uh dissipation is less and
would you would you uh respond to this
comment?
Um not 100% sure like I understand it
fully. I mean, if it's if it's about
triangle quality, yeah, I think there's
interesting things we can do with like
learned models. Um and I mean, classical
solvers have really strong dependence on
like good well-conditioned meshes, which
but with learned models, it might not
necessarily be true. We haven't really
tested it because I mean, in the end,
you also need training data for that.
And so, like you have to think about how
to generate training data for like bad
meshes so you can actually deal with
those at test time.
Uh but I think like fundamentally, there
yeah, I guess probably much more you can
do to compensate for something like
that.
Uh I think there was probably another
element in this comment. Uh I don't
know. Did you pick up on something else,
Alvaro?
Yeah, I'm I'm not sure like the part
about the dissipation like what it mean
like what like sort of like what I find
is like neural networks are like very
good at producing like high contrast
outputs.
Like for example, in this other paper
that I was kind of like mentioning
before, we found that like if you take
the same simulator and you run it at
like lower spatial resolution, then it
gives you an answer that like it's still
like it still has like the
correct physics, but maybe it's much
more affected by numerical viscosity. Um
so kind of like our model, you can use
it just to model the entire system, or
you could maybe just, you know, use it
to correct the the other model and
compensate for numerical viscosity. So
in this sense, our models can be very
good at this, and this is why the videos
look good because, you know, the neural
networks are good at producing states
that look like the real state. Um and I
think
they can be complemented easily with
like other models.
Uh and, you know, probably for science,
for actual like scientific applications,
in many cases they they kind of like
winner combinations will involve
combining them with something that is
that you know that has nice properties,
or maybe tells you something about the
physics, even if it's not correct, and
then use the model to correct that.
Um if you want to have more guarantees.
Okay, thank you. Uh the next question is
by Piyush. Um any thoughts on uh graph
level predictions? Any specific type of
models that work better in those kinds
of problems? Um should one use global
node read out or an MLP on aggregated uh
node attributes? Yeah, so um so to
answer this, this this is a very
interesting question, and in most
applica- in lots of applications, you
don't know which should you which one
you should use. Uh now, the main problem
here is that like often when you work
with graph networks, you want to
generalize to larger graphs. Um and if
you actually have a global component in
the graph that can communicate to
everything, and then a single output,
then it can be very easy
uh for the model to to overfit to the
sizes of the graph that it was trained
on. So, if you when you generalize,
you're planning to generalize to graphs
that are larger, I usually recommend to
try to not use a graph network with
globals. Keep Keep like pure message
passing, and then have all of the nodes
or all of the edges contribute via a
linear operation to the answer in a way
that when you scale to the graph, maybe
you know, it would just be a linear
operation. So, there will not be a a
neural network that will get surprised
by receiving like the sum of, you know,
40 elements where at train time it only
it only saw 20 elements. Um but this is
a very interesting question. It really
depends on the application. And I think
it's one of the big challenges. So,
something else that people have tried to
is you can use a different aggregation
function for the globals. You can use
that something like a mean or a max or
or a or for the globals, which, you
know, is less sensitive to the size of a
system. Uh and then for the messages,
you continue using a sum for the node
aggregation of messages. So, it's really
like a very interesting question, and
I'm afraid, you know, beyond that
intuition, I cannot really give you a
rule of thumb because there's there's no
right answer, I think. It depends on the
application.
There's also another approach that
sometimes people take is but
specifically for things like point
clouds or like stuff that has
geometrical structure, which is you take
your whole graph, and then you have a
down-sampled graph, and you connect
these edges, and you kind of go down
level by level, similar to like CNN
models often like converts down to like
a very low like step by step to kind of
a lower resolution. And in the end, you
read out on those nodes, right? So, like
uh
DGCNNs and stuff like that do that. And
there's a lot of like shape models do
similar things. And I think it's the
idea is that you can capture both local
and global information this way better.
But it really depends what you're doing,
as I was saying.
Okay, thank you. Uh the next question is
by Boxiong. Uh for a chaotic system, is
the simulated state space same as the
ground truth state space? Is it possible
to pose some state space level
constraints as useful inductive biases?
I'm not sure I understand the question.
Uh,
if you're there uh Yeah, if you want to
just move Yeah, do you want
So, yeah, I think to answer the
question, we're not modeling a latent
space. So, when we do when we when we do
kind of like one step model, it's always
going from the ground truth state space
like you know, spatial coordinates in
the real world back to spatial
coordinates in the real world. Like
another option would be to have a model
that like does what we would call a
latent rollout, uh, you know, which is
you do the same thing without going to
the back to the spatial world. Uh, in
practice we find that like you know, we
didn't need to do that. So, we it it it
was easier to keep it simpler but just
going back and forth from the real world
all the time. Was that Was that the
question?
I was wondering that we are just using
the mean square error as some
some guidance to train the network,
right? And uh, we this might not provide
really informative guidance to to learn
the from one step to a net to a next
step. And in a chaotic system, so we
have we have all of these the states
estimations and we may generate a PDF of
this whole trajectory of a simulated
system and the original system. And if
would they match? If they do not match,
can we use this as some inductive bias
to to constrain the network?
Yeah, I mean there's certainly a lot of
other things we can do. I mean we
haven't really experimented with any of
that. I mean we mostly use L2 like
direct L2 loss cuz we know that's easy
to optimize.
Um,
I mean, with that I mean you can also do
that not necessarily on things like
position. You can also do that on other
things, you know, these systems have
right like for
for turbulent system. I'm not sure like
necessarily what's the what's the thing
you want to concern your learning by,
but like certainly for like, I don't
know, for fluids what a lot of people do
is say like, "Oh, well, I know if it's
incompressible, I know my divergence is
zero. So, I put that in my loss, right?"
And there's like a lot of other stuff
you can add depending on
information that you know of your
system, right? And so, we didn't really
go into that game very much, but there's
certainly like a lot of application
specific papers do that.
Yeah, thank you, but our question is
that many of the efforts are are going
through the like the simulating part.
What about the like if there any other
way to training using graph neural
network to trying to provide some other
guidance beyond L2 norm?
Oh, you mean like things like GANs and
stuff? Yeah, like graph graph-based GAN
have some learning loss function in
graph neural network. Is there any
progress in that direction?
Not super Do you know a bit more on
that, Oliver?
Uh
I mean, so far like our approach has
kind of like been the opposite. Like,
we've we've several times in the past
discussed the idea of like using GANs
for a for a simulation,
but like it was kind of because MSE was
working fine. We didn't want to kind of
like make it our lives hard, but like
having to train GANs which you know are
very well known to be like much harder
to train. But, there's certainly no one
We went When we think about like how we
would extend these models to a
stochastic systems, uh
GANs are definitely like one of the
options. And
uh and you know, we we have like tried
some things in the past, but like we
haven't really explored that direction
much.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, thank you. Uh the next question is
by Francisco. Have you ever tried to use
inductive biases based on invariance to
lie group transformation, group CNN, or
other differential geometry notions,
geometric deep learning in general. What
is your opinion on this matter? Do you
see possible future developments there?
So,
we we have played with these ideas a
little bit. The answer is a little bit
similar to the previous one. For for the
sort of challenges that we have set
ourselves so far, we didn't have to go
into these directions. We anticipate,
you know, actual actual like
you know, more kind of like powerful
geometry representations inside of
neural networks
could actually paid off once you
actually want to generalize more from
like, you know, low data regions to
large data regions. And you know, I
think here we're actually talking about,
you know, inductive biases inside of the
model, but like even something as simple
as like having a model that's
rotationally equivalent or, you know,
equivalent to like, you know, whatever
lie group, you know, rotations, mirror,
um
mirror symmetries and stuff like that,
it will only make the model like more
data efficient to it, but like so far we
haven't found that like for the datasets
that we had, this was really necessary.
But it's certainly like
a very nice kind of like a research
direction and, you know, we would love
to see papers published in this and we
would love to read them, too.
So.
Yeah, I mean, translation is the the
only thing we do and that we got like a
lot out of, I have to say. Like, we had
initially just worked with absolute
positions. But that's like
all the generalization stuff is only
possible because of that. Rotation is a
little bit, I mean,
yeah, it will give you a little bit less
bang for the buck cuz it's very easy to
do that with data augmentation, but
yeah, the all of these is very very
interesting directions.
Okay.
Next question is by
have people cast traditional PDEs over
us to use NN framework without any
learning so as to use the high speed GPU
infrastructure. I don't know if this
makes sense or is possible.
I I think people are doing this, yes.
And especially like right like now for
this papers we use TensorFlow and for
like apart from TensorFlow we also use
something that is called Jax.
Um
and Jax is TensorFlow is kind of like
written more for machine learning even
though you can use it for this. But this
other TensorFlow Jax is actually written
not as a machine learning framework but
more as kind of like a distributed
compute framework with GPU acceleration,
GPU compatibility, all of this. So I
think in I don't remember any specific
cases but like in kind of like workshop
talks in the past I've certainly been
people seen people writing simulators
using those machine learning frameworks.
And yeah, it's I think it's a great idea
and it's it's you know these frameworks
are written to to be kind of like make
using accelerators easy to people. So
like
very often like I know I know some
people that like you know write
simulators and they maybe they don't
want to use Jax or TensorFlow because
they don't want to have an additional
dependency. But you know, to me the the
wins of being able to use that if if you
can is just like immense because then
you can write like a high performing
simulator in Python. So which to me is
amazing.
Yeah, there's like a lot of work on
writing differentiable solvers without
necessarily any like neural network
learned components. Um particularly like
one that comes to mind is PhiFlow from
like Niels Thuerey's lab at TUM which is
like a differentiable fluid solver for
it in TensorFlow. And like yeah, people
don't necessarily write those they are
fast even though that you can do that.
They write them generally because then
it allows you to put a little bit of a
learned component in the middle of this
whole solver and then like uh
like differentiate through the whole
thing and just like learn gradient based
updates and apply a little component. Um
so there's a lot of work in that area.
Okay, thank you.
Well, I would like to comment the
following comment. There's the recently
we have developed a non-linear manifold
reduced to model where we use the
non-linear the manifold representation
as a neural net and then plug that into
the traditional PDE solvers and probably
Matt or even Alvaro and Toby you want to
check that out. Okay, the next question
is by
Dolly Shin.
Thank you for the talk. Did you have any
general requirements for the
physics-based simulation models for
training?
In general, as the computational cost
became cheaper than in the past, people
in computational mechanics are trying to
catch up with more accurate results
using more complex simulations. Is this
coinciding with the database that these
data-driven modeling requires?
Um,
I'm not necessarily sure exactly what's
going but I mean for the
the way we picked the data like of the
data sets to train on, it's like there's
things that play more to the strengths
of a model than others. So, for example,
like like one very strong inductive bias
you put in is that
like interactions are local and message
passing propagates information and
that's like um
true for like a lot of these like
dynamic
equations but like if you have something
that's like instantaneous or very fast
like long-range interactions, there's
probably less good prior, right? And so
like there's there's a little bit of
that kind of requirement. But that's not
necessarily much beyond that. I mean,
you can kind of use whatever data you
want to train this thing. It's just like
some things play more to the strengths
than others.
Um, I'm not sure there was another
element to this question that I didn't
get.
Is there anything you want to add, the
Alvaro?
No? Okay. Okay, next question is by Fay.
The edge embeddings depend on depend on
the displacement vector according to the
paper and do not seem to be explicitly
rotationally invariant. Are the current
GNN prediction rotationally invariant?
So, the current model is not
rotationally invariant as we kind of
like said before,
right? Like answering the other
question.
So, yeah, in principle we we we we kind
of like played with this idea and like
what we find is like there's kind of
like a bunch of like rotationally
equivariant models out there. Most of
them were kind of like designed for
molecular property prediction for kind
of like, you know, low data regimes
because I mean, you know, when you're
working with molecules like any regime
is like low data regime because there's
too many molecules in the test set. So,
like in principle for this data set we
never needed to use this, but this is
actually something that we're interested
on and, you know, if if there's any any
particular
equivariant model that you're interested
on I'll be
I would be very happy to kind of like um
follow up on that if if you want to
share it.
Um
I guess that's it. The I I think
great great job. You are the rockstar. I
mean, you you you you you banged all the
all the questions posted in the chat
room. Um is there any other
questions by I mean, you can unmute
yourself and then direct directly ask
those questions.
Um
If not, we can ask John. Um just quick
one quick question. Toby,
can you like comment out like comment
out comment on the difference and
similarities between these graph neural
network models and, you know, classic
reduced order modeling, you know, model
reduction, PCA, you know, like some of
the work Dr. James Yarbrough did.
You know, like those real-time subspace
simulation.
Mhm. Yeah, sure. There I mean there's an
obvious
similarity. I mean generally like
learned like models using neural
networks and PCA there's a little bit of
similarity in that like yeah, you learn
like a
different type of space in which like
your predictions are much easier to do
with. And like I think like specifically
what's more similar to that kind of like
um
reduced models is something like you
just take your mesh or take your grid or
whatever. You put everything into one
latent, right? And on this latent you do
then prediction, right? And this is like
a very low-dimensional latent. This is
kind of like what I think there's a
bunch of papers even combined with a
PCA, but like you can think about as as
a like a non-linear version of PCA,
right? And this kind of works. It has
some advantages cuz it's not linear,
things like especially like collisions
and whatever
are often hard to express with linear
PCA.
Um but I think like the main difference
between our model specifically in these
methods is that it's like not
compressing everything into a single
latent. We still exploit this um
exploit structure to a degree because we
are operating on these graphs and we're
learning local rules on this graph,
right? And this is something that gives
you compositionality, right? Like this
is the the only reason why our models
generalize at all versus that is
something that's really hard with PCA. I
mean it really only works if you have a
very small set of dynamics that you want
to learn and compress into like your
your your PCA basis, right? Versus if
you have some sort of like structure
then that you can compose like this
graphs, then it's much more likely to
apply to an a very like a an unseen
scenario.
Okay, thank you so much.
Is there any other questions? I I guess
Oh, okay, there is one more.
Uh by Paradeep.
Uh do the results have any sensitivity
towards to mesh scaling factor or mesh
quality used during the training.
I mean, we haven't really experimented
much with that. So, we just took the
meshes that our simulators gave us,
which are very different. Like, you can
see like the the ones we got from
console are very regular meshes. Like,
the cloth simulation gives us much
crazier meshes that are much more like
elongated. Um
And I mean, we didn't have any problem
with that. I think like I mean, probably
the the limits for a neural network
model are like actually like much higher
than they are for classical methods
anyway. They probably can compensate for
a lot. But, it's not something we
necessarily tried um much with.
Um
Yeah.
Okay, thank you so much. Oh, okay. Well,
I let's wrap it up um here. Um I mean,
we I mean, I sounds like we can go on
and on, but
Uh if you have additional questions,
please um directly, you know, contact
Tobi and Alvaro. Um they provided the
email address to you guys at the end,
you know, at the last slide, right? Um
so, please contact them directly.
Okay, I mean, you guys did awesome job
today uh with all all those difficult
questions. Uh you
you really uh rocked it. Uh let's thank
our speakers
for the wonderful uh the presentations
and then wonderful Q&A sessions.
And um
you know, keep up the good work.
Thanks. Thanks. Thank you for inviting
us. It was great. Uh no problem. Well,
uh Tobi and Alvaro, if you can stay um a
little bit longer. Um so, there are some
some group of folks uh who is a
real fan of you, right? So,
um yeah. Other than that, uh let's
adjourn. Uh let me finish the recording
here.